okay so for those of you guys who have
been following comics explain for a
while you guys know that there was a
point where i did videos where they were
kind of like
you know they could be better right i
was never really that proud of them and
slowly and steadily over time we've been
kind of reworking them uh remastering
them as i call it okay so blue marvel
right adam brashear he is without a
doubt probably my one of my single most
favorite superheroes in all of comic
books because this origin story is
insanely amazing it's one of the best
written comic book origin stories of all
time in the history of comics and this
is coming from a guy who's been reading
comics for 25 years so i know what i'm
talking about those are the guys out
there who have been reading even longer
you guys know what i'm saying right so
here's the thing this initially picks up
and basically that with the mighty
avengers facing off against a guy by the
name of anti-man and there's a little
more tomb we'll find out more about his
origin but here's the important thing
about the mighty avenger because a lot
of you guys have probably never heard
about this team and for non-comic book
readers you may assume it's just a
colloquial way of like referring to the
avengers not true the mighty avengers
were an actual team so the idea behind
this is kind of sidetracked from this
story for a second and go back to
marvel's civil war event so when marvel
had civil war they released the
superhuman registration act and the
superhuman registration act required
that superheroes basically register
themselves with shield and their their
government and so on and so forth and
that led to things like the 50 state
initiative the bad guys quote unquote
reed richards and and tony stark and
ant-man hank pym the guys who were in
support of superhuman registration they
won and so what you ended up getting was
alongside the traditional avengers team
which was led by like iron man and those
guys and then you had their antithesis
which was the secret avengers absent
captain america you had the mighty
avengers and the mighty avengers
initially were really nothing more than
like a police arm more or less of like
superhuman registration and stuff like
that they were led by carol danvers and
they were tasked with like tracking down
superheroes it kind of changed as time
went on and began to sort of modify now
superhuman registration basically ended
with a siege on asgard event in 2010
which was kind of the start of the
heroic age or led into the heroic age
but uh nonetheless this team is
basically a team of some of the heaviest
hitters that marvel had at the time i
say some of them not all of them right
so you've got wonder man simon williams
you've got the wasp you've got black
widow you've got yellow jacket which is
just one of the different identities of
hank pym you got iron man you got carol
danvers who at the time was known as
miss marvel this is before we got the
kelly sue taconic run which is when uh
miss marvel transitioned from her
namesake to becoming captain marvel
you've also got the century and she-hulk
now the century is of particular
importance here and the reason why is
because with this fight aerys a god of
war he's he's he's okay and he's cool
but when these guys are facing off
against anti-man they're getting
absolutely decimated the fact that this
guy was able to go toe-to-toe with the
sentry is insane because the century is
one of these characters where he's kind
of like marvel's version of superman or
one of marvel's versions of superman
marvel's also got characters like blue
marvel himself which is very much a
superman s character but this the fact
that these guys are able to hold their
own the fact that you know anti-man is
able to go toe-to-toe with a man like
this century who's so astronomically
powerful is quite impressive now
ultimately they end up get getting the
upper hand on this guy but the whole
thing about anti-man is he keeps
spouting this idea that like the planet
basically like humanity needs to die the
humanity is a plague is causing nothing
but problems on the world that like the
best thing to do is to wipe out humanity
and to just start over but in the middle
of this whole conflict he makes this
off-handed statement if the blue marvel
couldn't stop me what chance have any of
you guys and that's true right because
the blue marvel is a powerhouse that's
that's the thing man like adam brashear
dude this guy is on a whole different
level of power it's absolutely insane
but but as soon as he makes that comment
within moments he basically starts to
vanish he just kind of starts breaking
down and disappearing and nobody really
knows where he goes to at this point
it's just kind of regrouping right you
have like the sentry you got all these
guys and the sentry makes this this
comment like he's never fought someone
so powerful before and this was really
just like kevin grievous the guy who
created this story establishing just how
powerful anti-man is because the sentry
is one of these characters where when he
gets involved into a fight he almost
never loses the only exception to that
is how marvel kind of treats his
character which sort of sucks but to
give you guys perspective on the power
of the sentry this is a guy that has
multiple personality disorder so as
clark can't ask persona if we can call
it such a thing it's robert reynolds
that's him in just his baseline human
form the version you see here where he's
like golden and he's got the hair and
everything that's century so that's like
if if he had if he was basically
superman then the question is what if
superman were a bad guy and that's the
void now the void's power is limitless
right there's no real way to defeat the
void there's one story like a what-if
story where he basically kills all the
superheroes on earth and then goes out
into the universe and kills everybody
else the void persona of the century
there's one point when he first shows up
in brian michael bendis's new avengers
where like the combined forces all right
this is the combined forces the combined
forces of the fantastic four the
avengers and the x-men are not enough to
stop the void it's insane it's it's just
i mean we're talking about like full
contingents right so like all the
avengers all the fantastic four all the
x-men none of them are powerful enough
to hold this guy off when they're all
working together it's just an insane
level of power so what we end up doing
is while they're regrouping we jump back
to 1962 and this is where the story gets
amazing right this is where the story
just gets absolutely mind-blowingly
amazing so you jump back to blue marvel
himself facing off against anti-man and
in this initial skirmish where the two
of them are are fighting each other we
kind of get anti-man doing the same
saying the same thing he was before that
humans are beyond saving right there's
there's no way to bring them back right
humans are just kind of this hopeless
thing right now it's not really meant to
say that i guess it does seem a little
nihilistic right a little you know
cynical but it's one of these things
where once the story comes into full
view and you get the full context of
what's going on that anti-man is
actually not wrong all the world's
problems happen because of people right
it's not some kind of invisible hand out
there that's moving things around you
know some invisible specter that makes
bad things happen all the worst things
in the world happen because of people
but the other side of that coin is all
the best things in the world happen
because of people we as people we're
complicated and we're messy we're
hypocritical we do things that don't
make any sense right there's no real
rhyme or reason or logic to human beings
right if we were entirely rational
beings we wouldn't really have emotion
if emotion was logical it wouldn't be
called emotions so because of that you
know we as people are messy but that's
kind of the big difference between blue
marvel and anti-man anti-man is
exceedingly cynical of humanity he views
humanity as people who just if if people
wanted to fix the world they would have
but they haven't so they don't want to
that's the perspective that anti-man has
of the world blue marvel is a lot more
hopeful in the sense of saying like they
will stumble they will fall they'll
screw up but in the end our job as
superheroes is to help them become
better right to show them a better way
we could force humanity to operate the
way that we want them to but that's not
what we're here for and so ultimately
you kind of have this back and forth
battle going between the two and i mean
this is back and forth like picking up
cars and throwing them buildings are
getting smashed and this is i mean this
is not designed to display the full
totality of their power right it's not
like ah blue marble can pick up a car
and that's where he peaks that that's
that's not what this is designed to show
that's not what this is designed to do
believe me he's much much stronger than
being able to pick up a car but at the
end of the day anti-man basically just
kind of establishes that he can't really
be redeemed here right he can't there's
no real saving him there's no real like
getting him to come back from the edge
and talking him down the only way for
blue marvel to defeat him is to
basically stop him the only way he knows
how to pummel him and essentially kill
him right that kind of that kind of
seems to be how it is now he doesn't
necessarily kill him but he does beat
him within an inch of his life right now
here's the important thing and this is
why the legend of blue marvel is so
significant when it comes to the black
community and comic books what ends up
happening here is in the middle of once
this whole fight is over he emerges from
the rubble but his mask is torn now
notice everybody was cheering him on
right everybody was like yeah yeah
everybody was cheering him on and
remember this takes place in 1962. when
his mask is torn and he comes up people
realize he's black right switch over to
the pentagon war room the pentagon war
room of course you have you have robert
mcnamara you've got the president of the
united states at the time john f kennedy
you've got a whole bunch of people who
are here but the biggest issue that the
thing that they're talking about is they
the world in the united states has come
to the realization that amer that the
americas and even the world's most
powerful superhero is a black man now
here's the thing to know at the time
this story was written or at least the
the point this story takes place in
which is in 1962 this predates the
arrival of the fantastic four spider-man
the x-men all that kind of stuff uh you
know in inside continuity mutants are
still like emerging mutants are like
popping up here and there so like
charles xavier the leader of the x-men
is alive james hallett wolverines
running around doing his thing right so
like mutants exist here but in terms of
superheroes who are operating out there
in the world and doing things to protect
the world blue marvel is one of the only
ones in the united states we can largely
kind of assume there are maybe some
others but like the fantastic four have
not gone into space and gotten their
powers yet peter parker has not been
bitten by a radioactive spider yet so
that's kind of why you don't really see
peter or any of those guys jumping in
there but one of the important things
that kevin grievous does here when he
writes this is he talks about this he
really kind of introduces the sort of
nature of adam beshear and basically
saying he's not just some black guy who
got some powers and is doing things now
right this guy is what the black
community we kind of refer to as black
excellence which is to say great
examples of black individuals in the
black community this is a guy who
basically graduated magna [ __ ] laude from
cornell in 1954 with an electrical
engineering phd and a phd in theoretical
physics right this guy is super genius
right he's super smart but notice the
words that are being used here right
definitely not your average color the
nature of this comic the way it was
written by kevin grievous was to reflect
the language at the time and that's one
of the reasons why you see all these
different things because the question
becomes how powerful is he right and
then we start learning things like there
was an asteroid or a meteor that was
heading towards earth that was the size
of kansas and he stopped it right he
basically sent it away that the the
enterprise was damaged in the pacific
that he lifted this aircraft carrier out
of the water and took it to a to took it
to a better location right there was a
hydrogen bomb incident one of the things
they basically that's really being
established to us here is this guy is
not necessarily a protector of the
united states right that's the big thing
to hit out here he's done some things
that have benefited the united states
but it's not as though this meteor was
headed towards earth and the meteor was
like oh my god i'm about to hit china
i'm sorry let me divert my course and
attack the united states right a meteor
the size of kansas hitting the earth
would certainly be like a in an end of
the world scenario right an apocalyptic
situation and that notion of him being a
protector of the people is something
that's exceedingly important but one of
the other conversations they're having
here is that in the current social
climate which is to say during the time
this story takes place or this kind of
flashback takes place is during the
civil rights movement that the
government's afraid the government's
afraid and sort of scared of what all
this might mean now in terms of what the
government's actually afraid of that
core particular thing that comes by way
of us switching over to adam bashir when
he's requested by president kennedy and
he's basically brought you know along
you know by the secret service to the
white house but along the way we get
this kind of flashback you know sort of
a flashback in a flashback of his time
when he was fighting in the korean war
because he was a member of the us
military and what you end up getting
here is this scenario where you have
conor sims who was the friend of adam
brashear and that they ended up running
into an ambush during the korean war and
this guy actually saved the life of
conor simps but despite saving the life
of a fellow soldier who was a white guy
the result was that adam beshear was
never really never really accepted he
constantly ran into racism almost
everywhere he went being called all
manner of derogatory terms that were
designed to demean him right to bring
him down to tear him down and you even
have this situation where you have
members of the of the marine corps who
are telling him that like you can get
all the commendations that you want
right but like at the end of the day
you're still going to be a and you guys
know what it is they say right i mean of
course you kind of cut off before you
actually get that statement but in the
face of all of that he still holds
strong right because it's one of these
things where it's kind of like yeah i
mean you guys can call me that all you
want to but at the end of the day i've
achieved more in this life than you have
so what i don't hear is bigotry and
racism what i hear is jealousy and anger
right and so because of that it's it's a
kind of an amazing and amazing exchange
that goes on here but switching back to
the war room the conversation between uh
john f kennedy the president at the time
and bobby kennedy his brother we
basically get robert kelly stepping in
now robert kelly at this point in time
is working for the nsa and really robert
kelly hasn't actually run for senator
yet he will become senator at some point
in time but for those of you guys who
are not really familiar with senator
robert kelly when chris claremont took
over the x-men titles and even a little
bit leading up to the to his time taking
over the x-men senator robert kelly was
a guy who was staunchly against mutants
this is a guy who basically helped to
spearhead the events of project wide
awake now again we'll follow up with
what project wide awake means here in a
future video because it's it's the facts
it's one of these things where kevin
grievous kind of changed it up and
basically said it started with blue
marvel which was sort of insane right
because project wide awake was just a
huge event but basically you have
senator robert kelly who kind of comes
in and says look you know civil rights
is gonna reach a fever pitch here in the
next two years right this civil rights
movement in the next few years or so by
1965 1966 it's gonna be this colossal
movement right now it's it's coming off
the cusp of things like the montgomery
bus boycotts and stuff like that but
once it actually reaches like a national
a national scale and it grips the united
states then things are gonna get kind of
wild like this a guy with this level of
power is gonna upset the apple cart and
that's when you have bobby kennedy
basically coming to the aid of of robert
kelly and saying yeah this is true that
at the moment right now a man with this
kind of of power like what would happen
like the whole country turned on him in
a matter of months right and he makes a
statement and he says last week he saved
16 children from a burning orphanage and
white people threw rocks and bottles at
him right here they hurled racial slurs
that would make a clansmen blush and
this was up north he said if it's down
south some cop shoots him the bullet
ricochets kills an old woman and they're
not going to blame the cop who shot
they're going to blame him they're going
to blame blue marvel for that right he
says many of his own people collards
don't even like him they expect him to
be some sort of negro messiah and kill
all the white people they burn down
their own neighborhoods in protest
because he refused to lead them in a
genocide against white people and that's
really the core fear that the government
has the core fear the government has and
by extension white america has is that
what you have in the world right now is
this black man who is a superhero who's
performed these monumental feats who
cannot be killed by things like hydrogen
bombs or anything like that by no real
conventional means that exists can blue
marvel be destroyed and so if blue
marvel allied himself with black america
in the civil rights movement and turned
against the government then in turn
there'd be nothing the government could
do to stop him he could just go in there
kill the president and just sit and sit
in the white house and just say i run
this show now on the other side of the
equation black america hates blue marvel
because he's not siding with black
america during the civil rights movement
he's not signing and saying yes we have
to go fight the good fight and all that
kind of stuff he's not doing any of that
and so what you end up getting is this
point where kennedy is sort of stuck
between a rock and a hard place because
he's just kind of like what do we do in
this situation right i mean this is
supposed to be the world's decision what
do we do here and so ultimately once
once adam bashir gets to the office of
of kennedy there's a little bit of small
talk that goes on there right you know
that that you know when adam beshear was
in college he was an amazing football
player but the small talk vanishes
pretty fast right kennedy just kind of
says we both know why we're here that he
says my grandfather used to tell me
about the signs that said irish need not
apply and then adam responds and says
but they don't say that now do they and
so kennedy says i'll get right to the
point the world's afraid of you mr
beshear they have visions of a vengeful
superpowered negro taking over the world
right and and from there like at that
moment adam beshear jumps up and says
that's never my intention my intention
is not to use my power and to overthrow
white america and that's the stance of
adam beshear here he's not a superhero
to black america he's not a superhero to
white america he's not even a superhero
to america he's a guy who protects the
world right his allegiance is to the
world the notion of him somehow allying
himself with black america because he
happens to be a black man with powers is
preposterous and it's stupid for anybody
to believe that the other part of that
is the belief that he's going to somehow
tear up white america he's going to
eliminate all the power that white
americans have that that's nonsense as
well that's not his goal his goal is not
world domination it's not tako it's not
to take over everything his goal is to
be a superhero to lead the world into a
better place but at the end of the day
the the point that kennedy makes here is
it doesn't really matter what your
intentions are it's just what people
believe and this is a desperate time and
in times of desperation people will
believe what they want to believe
whether it is rational logical or
otherwise it doesn't matter people will
choose what they want to believe and
black americans choose to believe that
you are supposed to be some kind of
black messiah that's going to help them
overthrow white america white americans
choose to believe that you're going to
do that right that you are going to
somehow topple white america people are
afraid of you and so he says in the end
i have to make a call here and and where
you would expect kennedy being a guy who
did quite a bit during his presidency
you would expect him to kind of stand up
and say i sanction your actions as a
superhero and i will get out there in
front of the world and i will tell him
that if i if i need to that's not what
happens instead he presents him with the
presidential medal of freedom the
greatest honor that any president can
give any man and then says i need you to
step down i need you to walk away from
being a superhero at this moment right
now the united states simply can't
handle it we're too racially divided and
we can't have you go forward being a
superhero anymore let me tell you guys
something this story gets amazing after
this it gets even better because what
follows after this you pick up with the
modern day and it's tony stark's hunt is
iron man's hunt for blue marvel right
and the hunt is on and like as he goes
through every crap he goes through
everything right he goes he goes through
all kinds of stuff he's warned he's told
not to do not not to dig through things
it it gets super cool and if you think
this is where it stopped with the
federal government and their involvement
with adam bershear you you have no idea
you have it's it's
it's one of the best stories ever told
in comic books so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and i will catch you all
later
peace